bonsoir à tous après les indiens
d'amazonie nous allons nous intéresser
ce soir à une autre cause perdue le
service public
je suis ce soir au coeur du plateau de
double jeu tel qu'il était conçu
initialement à la base au départ c'est
un décor magnifique
je vais essayer à présent je me frayer
un chemin parmi ce public étrange et
bigarrée la vigueur et sont là
un public on ne rencontre son côté un
autre plateau de télévision
rappelons que cet endroit a été classée
réserve nationale grâce à jack lang
double jeu est une émission qui fait
environ 4 ports dimap jury mais c'est
nerveux
j'aperçois à présent thierry ardisson
l'animateur de double jeu il n'a même
pas des dépôts c'est nul c'est ringard
keryx et à quoi personne n'y croit c'est
notre séquence perdition
au revoir bienvenue entre l'hébergeur
pour double je
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu